c'est dans les années 90 que les
regroupements de communes se sont
développés avec plus de 30 mille
communes de moins de 1000 habitants
ces rassemblements devenait nécessaire
pour faire face à des dépenses
d'aménagement de plus en plus coûteuses
les municipalités mettent en commun une
partie de leur budget et c'est le
conseil communautaire composé de
représentants des municipalités qui
décide des projets qu'il financera des
projets d'envergure tels que
l'aménagement de zones d'activités de
pépinières d'entreprises des programmes
de construction de logements de parcs de
stationnement mais aussi des projets
d'équipements culturels ou sportifs
comme une piscine un stade une salle de
spectacle au quotidien
l'intercommunalité peut prendre en
charge le ramassage des déchets son
recyclage l'assainissement de l'eau lors
des prochaines élections municipales
cette intercommunalité va franchir une
nouvelle étape puisque c'est vous qui
élirait directement vous conseiller
communautaire les intercommunalités
gèrent des budgets qui sont aujourd'hui
de plus en plus important il est donc
normal qu'ils viennent légitimité
démocratique plus fort aujourd'hui
jusqu'à présent les élus intercommunaux
était élue au second degré par les
conseils municipaux
ils seront maintenant directement élue
par les citoyens
les 23 et 30 mars vous élirez donc en
même temps vos conseillers municipaux et
vos conseillers communautaires